okay welcome every time we have
professor of aming at NYU Stern School
of Business Scott Galloway former
Governor Andre coros top a Melissa G Roa
former governor of New York Andrew Cuomo
okay first question
is for
you is Trump right to think that the
cases that Alvin brag and tis James
brought against him are politically okay
well there's a reversal right because
the same people right Alvin brag that's
the one about the uh tush money to
stormmy Daniels right and tis James is
the one about his business dealings
apparently he's a
crook
uh is Trump right to think those cases
are politically
motivated the um first Trump has never
right in my book just just
start was there was there ever a time
when you were friend I mean he goes way
back in New York as you do he goes way
back we're both from Queens knew our
families knew each other uh I dealt with
him extensively through Co literally on
a daily basis uh no we were never
friends okay the what is interesting
about the question is the there was
actually a poll Alvin brg the Manhattan
district attorney brought the first case
against Trump this is before Mar Lago
before January 6th uh which were in my
opinion frankly more serious cases but
they did a poll after Alvin Bragg
brought the case 76% of Americans said
it was politically influenced 76% 76% of
Americans don't agree on the color of
the flag right but 76% said it was
politically influenced and I think that
is telling bill because if if uh we
don't trust government we don't trust
the media Etc if this country believes
that the justice system itself is then
politically tainted then we have real
trouble because then you're on the
precipice of Anarchy uh but that's what
I found telling about that it was more
the public opinion uh was so high that
politics is influencing the justice
system and I mean Trump is the kind of
guy the more he goes to jail the more
popular he becomes it's like he's it's
Street Credit he's like a
rapper but it's true true it's
absolutely true and also I I never
thought they should have brought the the
stormy down one and and the fact that
there's four one it just to the people
who don't follow it closely you know
they should have just had one one he's
generally a piece of
Tri about all one Omnibus piece of
and the stormmy Daniels case the
Stormy Daniels case it's like you're
asking America to then think of this
former porn star as a hero and Michel
Cohen who's a known liar and fixer as a
hero and it was really books and Records
case that was upcharged to beat the
statute of limitation so yeah it made it
really easy to roll your eyes on the
other ones that were more serious the
fear is that hush money or inflating
your assets it does reduce the veracity
of much more serious crimes right
including nuclear secrets and trying to
overturn the peaceful transfer of power
I think it was just a tactical error to
go after the first
two Melissa is there a way to make
politics less about personal vendettas
and more about governing yeah again
that's why I said at the beginning I I I
see why you two are pissed because like
I mean Democrats at their best I think
are wonks and I mean that as a great
compliment is the one thing that
Republicans you don't usually find
Republican wonks they Reagan give me on
one page Bush give me to get on one page
you know they're one pagers and that's
government is complicated and I know you
two put in the time government is
complicated and sometimes it requires
sharp elbows and sometimes it requires
you to have to be tough in order to be
effective but the thing I find so funny
about it is in the the reaction to my
book some of it is people saying oh this
is you know she wants to go out and
attack people that attacked them and I'm
like okay well there was a point when
you were comparing me to Hitler's
enabler but now we're like whoa whoa
whoa don't criticize anybody don't you
know don't call this out and really what
I find interesting is nobody wants to
talk about the facts of what happened
because when you look at the facts of
what happened it's so damning so it's
easy to make it about personalities and
about vendettas and about everything
else well I I feel like those things
carry the day to to answer that question
I asked you at the beginning you know
why would a liberal state with a liberal
paper go after a liberal Governor
because I'm sorry make it all about
Generations but a lot of the younger
generation who was raised on the phone
which makes you shady and passive
aggressive and mean and fake I'm sorry
it just does I don't I don't think you
think they care about policy first and
foremost I don't I think they take Glee
in this kind of they like taking
especially that nest of vipers that it's
Albany yeah no they love it it's it's
sport it's actual sport it's sport so
it's like he's on my same team that's
who gives a who team you know what
I'm on my team and it's you know so so
some now again I don't know what
happened and I don't know who's at
fault
but I know there's two sides okay um
Scott how can we prevent China from so
from using AI to sew chaos and disrupt
our elections well we
can't
it's too late you're about to see an AI
misinformation laa palooza in q1 and Q2
is Putin recognizes the fastest Blue
Line path between him and victory in
Ukraine is the reelection of Donald
Trump so if you're spending 70 billion
and 100,000 lives a year fighting a
losing war in Ukraine wouldn't you be
stupid not to spend five or 10 billion
on Albanian troll Farms AB tested
information and then an aore moral
management team and social media who
will feel really bad about the
misinformation the day after the
election when all the checks have
cleared we are about to see the
weaponization of media platforms that
have no Fidelity to the Commonwealth and
the Gru and
AI deposition Biden and Harris we're
going to see the first real externality
of Miss of of AI and q1 and Q2 of next
year in terms of misinformation around
the election but OIC still more
important
I I I I I I still don't have the answer
to that question
okay Governor cromo knowing what you
know now is there anything you would
have change about the way you would
administer Administration handled Co
okay that's the question we didn't get
to and I was going to read you the
propublica statement which they
basically said New York was the only
state now of course the Scandal the
issue involved that people don't
remember is that you know obviously this
is the beginning of the pandemic
everything was chaotic we didn't know
what was going on but uh we did know
this it mostly affected the elderly
people like most pathogens do they were
the most vulnerable so you allowed
people who had been in the hospital
older people from a nursing home now
they go to the hospital to go back into
the nursing home without testing them
that P propublica says you were the only
state to do it without testing them when
they went back into the nursing home and
that's what caused such death in the
nursing home yeah is that true no uh
short answer is no also remember you say
what we knew uh first this is Monday
morning quarterbacking by which I could
make the New York Jets champion right if
we could do this the when Co started it
was all the disinformation was amazing
right it was coming from China wet
Market zo Tropic virus it was going to
California and state of Washington so we
banned travel to C uh to China from
China it turned out that the China had
already spread it to Europe all the
European flights were coming to New York
JFK so it had been here for months and
it was
astronomical when we first found out
about it uh and Scott can appreciate
this they were projecting we would need
150,000 hospital beds to deal with the
number of infected we only had 50,000 in
the entire state of New York so we were
you did it to free up beds we were
afraid of losing hospital beds uh but
people who were in hospitals who were
considered medically stable who were
tested were sent to nursing homes if the
nursing home said they could treat that
person in a way that protects the other
people in the nursing home and that was
a way to make sure we had but it didn't
did it I mean they also I mean the same
organization prua says you counted the
number who died differently in other
words you only counted the ones who died
in the nursing home whereas many people
came from the nursing home and died in
the hospital and you didn't count those
you only counted if they died in the
nursing home which they felt was
deliberate well let me not get weedy
with you we got every day I did a
briefing and every day we collected
information from hospitals and from
nursing homes and we printed two numbers
on the screen every day this is the
number of people who died in the
hospital this is the number of people
who died in the nursing home which means
you had to go back every day to 1,000
hospitals nursing homes to collect this
data and there how many died in the
hospital this how many died in a nursing
home they then raised the question and
said well how many died in a hospital
who were originally in a nursing home
before they went to the
hospital that's a different question and
uh that actually took the state
controller a year to figure out and go
back back and do the audit but we said
there's how many died in in a nursing
home there's how many died in the
hospital different question how many
died in hospitals who were originally in
nursing homes you then have to go back
and forensic so you wouldn't do anything
differently I mean is it fair I would I
would run that number now which nobody
asked me for until months
later uh but it would have been you know
this is in the middle of Co and you're
asking all these people to do it County
but if that's a number that people would
have wound up wanting which they didn't
say for months bill I would have put
that number and for upfront in the
beginning people died in in a lot of
nursing homes simply because the people
who take care of the people in the
nursing homes are
poor and the poor people get Co but and
it goes back to incentives we have
social media algorithms that get more
engagement and more Nissan ads if they
call out people and really make them
look as stupid and as mean as possible I
was on the board of my kids school
during coid I wanted a harsher lockdown
policy and in retrospect I was wrong the
the the damage to kids of keeping them
out of school longer was greater than
the risk but here's the bottom
line myself our great people the CDC I'd
like to thank the governor we were all
operating with imperfect information and
we were doing our best so it's
it's so let's but let's laar from it
let's learn from it let's learn from it
let's hold each other accountable but
let's bring a little bit of Grace and
forgiveness in that the show the
West hold yeah but other states did do
it differently yeah I mean I I read
Florida asked for two negative coid
tests before you get back into the Nur
the look if you want to First on Scott's
point he's exactly right all the early
information was wrong as a matter of
fact a lot of it now not just from
president Trump Dr fouchy Who I have
great respect for early on said this is
not going to be a problem uh they said
it was you could contracted from
touching a surface we sprayed all this I
remember washing the mail and we had
yeah I still do by the way
the but we had no idea how infectious it
was for seniors versus uh children early
on we had no idea we didn't know if it
was Airborne if it was by touch so this
is then when I say it's it's all
hindsight now now you know and the way
Scott's exactly right you know how it
got into the nursing homes it got in
months before we knew it was here the
staff walked it into the nursing said
the poor people that's lot lot of what
it is and also I mean it's a war in war
people die and
Generals it's not like they're trying to
kill them but generals be generals have
to make decisions not all decision are
the right decisions you don't know till
after and to that point I mean when you
ask the question would you do things
differently I would do everything
differently every literally everything
there's nothing I would I never
understand these people that interviews
and they go do you have any regrets in
life no I don't no like what and that's
why we have to tell the story and we
have to understand it because there will
be another pandemic and we've got to
learn from this one so we do it better
the next time all right this is
uh make this the last one this is for
uh two New Yorkers here uh what do you
New Yorkers think of how mayor Eric
Adams and Governor Kathy
hul yes yes you pronounced it
right I take it you're a big fan have
have handled the city's migrant crisis
uh I saw today they're offering any of
these migrants this sounds like a game
show a plane trip to anywhere in the
world there's policy you don't have to
go home but you can't stay here you know
Ed cotch started that in the 80s to help
solve the homeless crisis in New York
City he was giving out oneway bus
tickets to the homeless population this
is not new see California is what they
said they did really they did it's
true so what do you think about how they
handled the migrant crisis I you know I
just want to say something in defense of
Mayor Adams immigration this migrant
crisis is by definition Federal crisis
it is this happened because of decisions
made by the Biden Administration and
they basically made them unilaterally
and then they didn't manage any of it
and so people started showing up the
governor's not stepping in the
president's not stepping in and so Eric
Adams is doing everything he can to try
to manage this influx of people which
the likes of which we haven't seen since
World War II in New York City he doesn't
have the money to do it he doesn't have
the human resources to do it or the
space the space New York's crowded to
begin with yeah and then it's like we
have to turn around and say thank you
because because the president's offering
to let us lease Floyd Bennett Fields
where we can put people it's like what
you caused this problem and we're
supposed to say thank you because you're
freeing up a field for us to build
migrant beds it's the craziest thing in
the world so I mean my my heart goes out
to Eric Adams because he really was put
in a terrible position and nobody else
is stepp
in but didn't some of these places sort
of deserve it I'll ask you this by
saying we're a sanctuary City like how
the these terrible racist border states
who were and then when they called their
Bluff and sent the migrants to them they
were like suddenly they weren't quite so
liberal what I call liberal in theory
people a lot of people are liberal in
theory and when the migrants arrived
they were like oh what the
that's the
sanctu sanctuary city was used during
Trump when we were talking about
illegals uh New York City said it was a
sanctuary city New New York State said
it was a sanctuary State many other
cities did also this has nothing to do
with Sanctuary these people are here
legally that's what we want to forget
they are Asylum Seekers they are here
legally under the law so it's not about
Sanctuary well they but for the federal
government to abrogate its
responsibility where we get to a point
where the Texas governor is really
deciding where migrants go send this La
we'll send this New York City winds up
with
130,000 and there's no federal oversight
or management and you give it to the one
level of local of government that is
least able to deal with it which is a
city
Administration uh and then the state
says you know you're on your own it's
crazy that's why I'm for Dean Phillips
for
president all right thank you everybody
appreciate
it